Hayek called our economic system a
marvel and we don't have enough aw at
the incredible stuff that our economy is
able to achieve with no one being in
charge hi I'm Russ Roberts I'm professor
of economics at George Mason University
and a research scholar at Stanford
University's Hoover Institution and I
try to write novels about economics not
particularly well
I want to try to do in the book is give
people an idea of the forces that create
order in our lives without deliberate
design the virtues of leaving things
alone
not just because freedom is good which
it is but because of what that freedom
produces when we are able to choose our
own path choose our own dreams I use the
example of bagels on a Sunday morning
when you show up at the bagel store and
you decide to throw a brunch at the last
minute there's plenty of bagels waiting
for you you don't have to call ahead a
guy who comes in two hours later doesn't
say where my bagels oh we gave him that
new guy he threw a bunch brunch we felt
sorry for him the guy across town
doesn't have it doesn't get told oh yeah
all the bagels went to this guy on the
other side of town because he went
through a brunch the profusion of
availability in our lives which is so
magnificent which is a lot which allows
us to be spontaneous to dream to plan to
try new stuff it's just so amazing
somebody who figures out how to use
lasers which seems like a very bad idea
for eye surgery and as a result we get
this incredible thing called LASIK but
at the same time they're laser tag
parlors the laser tag parlor people
weren't told no no no you'll have to
wait a few years we're busy devoting
resources to lasers or if I want to
become a great fitter person with better
diet and better health habits there's
all this food waiting for me there's
special clothes there's videos there's
trainers as fitness centers that amazing
thing but couch potatoes get their stuff
too all this stuff that could create
incredible conflict oh people are into
fitness let's have all the resources go
to them but if you want to just lay
around on the couch too bad yeah
everybody gets tough the people on the
couch they get new brands of potato
chips new flavors stuff to help them get
fatter with less healthy if that's what
they want the system serves us without
anyone designing it appreciating that is
one I think part of being a civilized
human being and two helps you make
better decisions and the voting booth
it's a case they might help you know
elsewhere in your life but it's just
part of what economics has to offer it's
really our deepest insight and it's been
forgotten so I tried to bring it back in
the book and tell them the form of a
novel so that it's a little more
interesting
people are gonna lecture
the world works who use the economic way
of thinking as a useful way to frame the
complexity of the world to help you
organize your thinking and of course
teachers and students who are explicitly
trying to understand the world are the
people I'm trying to touch with this
book but it's it's for your mom it's for
your uncle I think understanding how the
world works is just part of life
well when I write didactic fiction I'm
trying to do two things I'm trying to
deliver an educational message and I'm
trying to do in a package that's
relatively palpable relative to the
standard techniques so I like to say I
it's not Beach reading but you can read
it at the beach and you could learn
something along the way so what I try to
do is take a set of economic lessons and
embed them in a fictional story that
both entertains and if it's done well
helps make those lessons more vivid and
interesting
when you write a book that's called an
economic romance which my second book
was and this recent book the price of
everything is has some romantic scenes
people often complain they're not hot
enough spicy enough racy enough you
choose your generational word I always
exhale well you can write a sex scene
without causing people to giggle you
write that I can't do that so I end up
writing books that I'm afraid or PG at
best no people say an economic romance
is there any good parts I always say
well I hope the economics are part of
the good parts but don't get don't get
too excited it is PG at best so there's
a romance which is nice there is but
it's modest
I suppose all novels are didactic they
all want to teach something but some
were more explicit you know the most
successful didactic novel clearly is
Atlas Shrugged although you could argue
it's Oliver Twist
I mean Oliver Twist and the work of
Dickens was designed to touch the heart
and get people compassionate about the
poor in the current state of British at
the time British Poor Laws
so there's authors often have a lot of
different agendas but was the one that's
done the most damage beside my own I'm
not sure what one tragedy I think about
Atlas Shrugged that makes me very sad is
that it is supposedly in a survey the
second most influential book in people's
lives after the Bible one wonders then
why the United States is not a more
libertarian or Liberty oriented place if
that is the case I think what a lot of
people learn from Atlas Shrugged is is
the lesson that it's okay to be happy
which is a good lesson it's true it's
okay to be happy I don't think everyone
absorbed the economic freedom lessons
quite the way that they were intended